when I think about the concept of taking
a step back it's perspective you know so
many people they're just not winning the
perspective gaming they're not taking a
step back and looking at the whole
picture they're just so [__] focused
on the issue at hand it's not a negative
or a positive it's an agnostic framework
of perspective when you take a step back
and you realize all the great things
that are going for you I like taking a
step back because it's a micro patience
execution before you just jump and go
take a step back observe the whole
situation and make your moves it's
always how people maximize opportunity
and mitigate risk so take a [__] step
back and realize how great you have it
or what the real opportunity in the
situation is